when Mad Men happened I was friends with
John Hamm he played a cable guy on the
Sarah Silverman program so then he
called me and he's like hey I'm doing
this pilot on AMC you should audition
for it and I said uh uh I'm not gonna
audition for a pilot on AMC like I was
laughing that's that old movie channel
yes
you auditioned for Jumanji the role went
to Kirsten Dunst is that true or false
that is true as a kid did you go to see
Jumanji after yeah I saw Jumanji but I
liked it I liked Jumanji yes but do you
sit there and go [ __ ] why
didn't they take no I wasn't bitter
enough but then yeah
The Parent Trap Lindsay Lohan was the
girl in The Parent Trap right did you
audition for that uh yes you did did you
go see The Parent Trap with Lindsay
Lohan no I know I started to get bitter
at that point did you really it was hard
for you is it true
you auditioned for uh Les Mis right I
auditioned for Les Mis yeah you didn't
get it because you had laryngitis I did
I had laryngitis but I tried but I don't
know if that's why I didn't get it I
probably didn't get it because I wasn't
right for it Anne Hathaway got it and
she was great in that film she's better
than she got it
yeah that was your Academy Award
were you supposed to stop are in the
movie Gravity with Angelina Jolie of
course it ended up being George Clooney
and Sandra Bullock right and the movie
made a ton of dough and it was very
successful he did great you were
supposed you were the first choice
and you in fact well go ahead everybody
winds up doing what they're supposed to
do right and sometimes uh someone gets
in a motorcycle accident and then the
person who winds up doing the part kills
it and you say I couldn't have imagined
anyone else there I came on early in the
development process I don't think
Angelini was even attached at that point
right but uh Alfonso and I really kind
of hit it off and then by the time I
said you know Sandy Bullock is really
and I've heard stories like this from
Clooney himself where you kind of you're
involved in things and you just kind of
want to help whether you wind up being
in it or not because you like the people
involved and it was that kind of story
yeah but you were in it and then you
said you got out of it by telling the
director I can't work in this confined
space I don't want to be just locked in
a [ __ ] Tin Can for a whole movie what
I can tell you is I went to do a test
with a new sort of
multi-spherical camera thing they were
doing for how they were going to do all
the CGI and
um and I'm one of those guys who can be
comfortably uncomfortable pretty easily
right and I went in the morning to do
that and we did it for about 20 minutes
I said this is crazy how much longer
they go it's like another two to four
hours I said no it isn't it and you left
you gotta have boundaries you got to
leave before you flip out right you
think if you would know like Clooney got
a 70 million dollar paycheck off of that
movie and so did Sandra Bullock 70 mil
okay maybe you would have put up with
that [ __ ] harness if you'd known that
you know at the time it didn't it wasn't
clear if this thing would be huge again
you can uh any of us can have anything
but we can't have everything I was
thinking about your acting career you
come kind of blew off a big opportunity
this was the time when Mad Men I'm just
saying I have terrible instincts like
when Mad Men happened I was friends with
Jon Hamm he played a cable guy on the
Sarah Silverman program right so then he
called me and he's like hey I'm doing
this pilot on AMC you should audition
for it and I said uh uh I'm not gonna
audition for a pilot on AMC like I was
laughing that's that old movie channel
well you were even even more outrageous
you said to him listen I've got my own
TV show why do I have to go audition
Comedy Central yeah go [ __ ] off and then
oh I remember getting the script um I
mean these aren't offers or anything but
like my agent sent me the script for um
bridesmaids and I just read the title
and was like [ __ ] this
braids made and now that's probably my
I've seen that like 15 times 10 favorite
movies do you are you filled with regret
when something like that happens no you
don't you don't dwell on it watch
bridesmaids and go oh I should have
played this part of this part I just
watch it and I love it like I die
laughing every time and I remember when
I first came out like when I first was
working the pilot for friends was
floating around the uh script I heard
you were sort of offered something in
French 100 no no I was I was too yeah I
was younger but um I remember the script
going around and crying laughing at how
dumb the title was
dude
is that a problem sometimes when you're
a very smart comedian that you that
you're almost too hip for the room and
every everything is kind of silly and
stupid like friends is stupid oh I'm not
good at bridesmaid oh I'm not gonna go
on AMC like it's almost like you're too
smart for your own being my favorite
thing
the audition for friends yes and you
didn't get it and it's a heartbreaking
story you put your audition on tape
and you mailed it into the people at
friends right you sent it to them I was
doing a uh uh it's only heartbreaking to
me
the world got got Chandler Bing by
Matthew Perry which was I think a work
of Genius but don't you think you would
have been it's heartbroken I however did
but don't you think you could have been
a good Chandler Bing honestly I think it
could have been a decent one I don't
think I would have been at the level of
Matthew Perry I I on some level the and
I talk about this in the book that that
when you audition for something and
don't get it
it's only when you see somebody do it
not well that you get mad I don't get
mad when when I see a an actor hit it
out of the park it's like well of course
no wonder they gave it to that guy I'm
so glad you said that because I've asked
a million actors that same question I go
what happens when you don't get the
movie role and then you go to see the
movie and a lot of them say we don't
even go to see the movie but but you go
to see the movie and the guy kills it
yeah does it just like does it just
break your heart no it doesn't at all no
it's exactly the opposite and and for me
like I auditioned for Reservoir Dogs
right which uh was uh which you wanted
to be Mr Pink yes yes uh and well no
they wanted me to be Mr Pink what
happened was I I uh I was flying to New
York on a Saturday and I got this script
right before I got on the plane and they
said uh they want to meet you on Sunday
it's the only day that this that this
young director can meet with people in
New York and that's the only day you
have to do it and I goes on the plane
and I tried to read the script but if
you saw the movie it's all over the
place and you're like what is what are
these people talking about and who what
there was a robbery but then they're
cutting an ear off there's no script
there what is going on here right there
actually is a great but it's very
complicated but it's very complicated
and I just couldn't handle it on on
flight 007 going into to JFK so I read
as much of it as I could but I I
couldn't finish it and uh uh and I
thought oh God I'm gonna go into this
thing not really prepared and uh the
next morning though I get this call from
my sister that uh that her uh her
mother-in-law is ill she's got to go out
and visit her in Long Island and so can
I take uh her daughter uh can I take
care of her daughter and I go oh oh I
have a good reason that I can't go to
this audition now my goodness so I call
up the producer and I'm like I'm sorry I
can't audition for this thing uh and
he's like please please we really want
you to come in and uh and I was like
haven't you got this whole monologue
what is he talking about Madonna it's
hard to follow it's hard to follow and
uh and finally I just had to beg off and
not audition for and then being a
brilliant movie when did you did you go
see the most Steve Buscemi of course
and he's great and the nice thing for me
is that I know that I that that uh that
I wouldn't have got that part even if I
showed up you think so I really don't I
truly don't believe I would have well
you know uh you you say that but who
knows and and you're a really good actor
and I think when you see Steve Buscemi
gets it and then you see it was a great
movie that's just such a horrible part
of show business I couldn't handle that
um did you go to the theater to see the
movie I did I'm curious I was curious
and uh and I was blown away and uh uh no
Mommy I was mad I was mostly mad at
myself for not getting the script well
that's a good lesson yeah
when you're working with Leonardo
DiCaprio you do the movie Romeo and
Juliet with him you go later on and you
audition for the movie Titanic which was
a blockbuster you get the part they want
you for the lead in Titanic you turn it
down because you said it would be
redundant to be in a movie with Leonardo
DiCaprio and play his love interest yeah
I mean I
know if I like got that I think you did
I was up okay don't be modest
um you got the part Kate Winslet ended
up taking it right yeah it was going to
shoot in Mexico City where we had just
filmed Romeo and Juliet for another six
months I was uh I really needed another
experience when but now take me into
this yeah when Titanic and I'm thinking
back that movie one all kinds of Academy
Awards it was one of the biggest
Blockbusters of all time from a career
standpoint are you then saying oh my God
what did I do this would have been huge
this would have put me on the map uh you
know really solidified me I didn't I
mean I remember when Leo was deciding to
take that movie he really wrestled with
it it's a it was a profound choice and
really the question was do I want to go
often to the stratosphere right now and
I think he decided that he did and I
think I decided that I didn't you mean
when you read the script you knew that
it would be a game changer yeah so you
made the decision I think I really
wasn't ready to I had a lot more
developing to do as a person I knew I
wanted to go to college that is an
amazing thing to say no to stuff like
that that's something I've struggled
with my whole career it's very hard for
me to say no and there were things that
are offered to me that I know would be
big in my career and I feel like I have
to grab them I would think a young actor
should just say oh my the fame thing and
and the quote goes up and the money and
everything that comes along with the
Titanic if you're not deeply aligned
with that choice it's not it's not going
to serve you it's not going to benefit
you that is very evolved it's just true
weren't you offered Superman yes one
point were you offered to play the
Christopher Reeve role as Superman yeah
but you have to understand that that
when when Superman was made it was
written by Mario Puzo and it was all
tongue-in-cheek it was hysterical right
hysterical right so because it was all
tongue-in-cheek so like when Superman
first learns he can fly and he shows off
he does loop the loops this and the
typical eyes is that such a word sure
typical
I didn't ask about that word I think the
one you said isn't made up okay thank
you so much bad word that you said they
approach you about playing Superman
right so now I I read it I want to give
you an example of when when Lois when
when clock head is just devastated
because she's in love with Superman
physically the office is set up in in
the at the paper the Daily Planet
exactly right when if you go to in order
to get the Clark Kent's office you must
pass through close Lane's office you
understand to get there so there's no
other way in so one day Clark is so
pissed off
because she's in love with Superman he
goes out screw it you know and he this
is just a typical scene The Way It Was
Written in and he rips his clothes off
and he's got a Superman thing under
there and he goes Lois come in here
she goes come on in here so she comes in
and she looks at him she goes that's
sweet clock but yeah
that's how it was written and then she
walks out and he goes looks in the
mirror he goes maybe a little talk here
a little I mean it was all Kung and she
why didn't they make the movie with you
because they're not a director did it
and he did I mean you know Christian
Reeves God bless him right you know were
you pissed that you didn't get to play
Superman no because what happened it was
the Sulkin brothers and they they said
there was going to be two movies now at
the time I was very lucky I could do
whatever I want I could have done you
know the phone book I was that big right
anyway so I got a call from Brandon one
night that's Jimmy come on you're gonna
do this picture with me I said no no no
no no I need some laughs
[Laughter]
no no but that wasn't the reason he says
you got to do this picture with me today
and obviously it was a lot of that yeah
well I said but friend I said but Mom I
can't thesis what is it the money or
something no they played me plenty of
money has nothing to do with it he says
but come on I said you're going to be
there three and a half weeks I'm there
for like four months what what kind of
laughs we're gonna have together you'll
have your lamps and you'll take off and
you leave me alone that's right so he
says no no no no we work something out I
said Marlon you know they're making two
movies out of it not one right you're
gonna make two he says so what I'm doing
it and I said yeah but you don't have to
wear the suit and he would really hung
up in a bird
laughs
Bobby so once told me you were up for
the Costanza role in Seinfeld is that
true uh yes I was
how'd you blow that well I went in to
read for it and I was sitting on the
couch and I had the script and some guy
came over there's a lot of people in the
room there you know how to audition so
this guy's sitting next to me and he
says hey what do you think of the script
and I said well Jerry's a really funny
guy but whoever wrote this they don't
know dick about uh writing you know
sitcoms yeah and uh it was Larry David I
was gonna say that must have been Larry
David nice and so I didn't know and he
didn't say guess who I am and because
he's not like that and uh yeah he has a
pretty good sense of humor except for
that day and anyway so uh then it comes
time for me to go in and read and I walk
in and who's sitting there him him and
Seinfeld and George Shapiro and I said I
really don't have to bother auditioning
do I and they said nope
no but I've been up for Curb Your
Enthusiasm three times all right what
are you gonna do all right so that's a
really heartbreaking story it is
you were offered the role of Black Widow
in the Marvel series
yeah and that's a great role for your
Scarlett Johansson but that would have
been a great role for you too and a slam
dunk big role but you had to turn it
down because you're so [ __ ] busy that
you were doing Gulliver's Travels at
that point no no no no I actually do
want to clean up the story on College
troubles I was contracted to do galava's
travels I didn't want to do Gulliver's
Travels it was a bit of a heartbreaker
for me because I take such pride in the
decisions that I make and it they mean
so much to me the films that I do
so that was that was tough I don't even
understand how that happens because you
do Devil Wears Prada
the studio says we'll give you this film
but you've got a promise promise US
you'll do another film and make that
decision in a certain amount of time is
that is that the idea of it yeah and
they kind of have a bit of a hold over
you so there were other movies that I
would want to do and I'd say but I
really want to do this movie about young
Victoria and so at some point I think it
just became evident that I needed to get
rid of this optional picture deal
because it was gonna just hang over me
for a long time and I didn't want that
and
ultimately as hard as it was
I don't think anyone expected for the
hand to be forced I think you kind of
like hope that it isn't but it was yes I
care deeply very very much about the
choices I make that's all I have are the
choices that I make because after that
it's it's really left up to the Gods
like what happens you you usually don't
really have any idea why a movie catches
fire and why it doesn't but no I'm never
left with a feeling of regret when I
turn something down it is I know in 20
Pages if I love it if I it's ethereal as
to why I like it I don't know why I like
it I just love it
and I'm in or I'm out after 20 pages
so when you show up on the set of
Gulliver's travel because you're a
professional you're going to do the best
you possibly can for sure yeah of course
no I was never looking like a slapped
ass on set I'm not I would never ever do
that and no no one knew and I also
didn't talk about it with anyone on set
or anything because there are a lot of
lovely people in it who were heaven to
work with and I actually had a had a
really good time I had a laugh with all
of them but it irked my heart to
for it to have happened in the first
place but I ended up trying to I I will
always try and make the best of any
situation for sure